it seems to me that everything with this
shutdown and Obamacare and the debt
ceiling and all this nonsense is about
2016 and it's it's all the GOP guys
jockeying for position and I hate sort
of talking about this stuff too much
because it's years from now and then it
stops us from dealing with things that
we should be talking about now however
howard fineman wrote a really good piece
in HuffPost that talked about how
they're all just angling themselves to
become the nominee in 2016 and how
that's going to work through the primary
process and all that and you know he
talked obviously about Ted Cruz who's
become like the hero of the Tea Party
which started with his 21-hour
filibuster that wasn't really a
filibuster Rand Paul gets the
libertarian wing Marco Rubio you know he
had that immigration bill that was sort
of do a Paul Ryan's obviously going to
be in the mix because of his pdx 90 abs
and then and then chris Christie of
course who's not in Congress right now
so he may be the winner here because he
doesn't even have to get in the fray of
this whole big mess so again I don't
really like it into this stuff but we
sort of got to talk about it because it
gives context to why everything's so
broken because three years before the
election these guys are doing things to
position themselves so if we ignore it
it's still it's still happening right
yeah I may not know a lot about politics
but I know a lot about being broken so
as a broke as a broken person are you
constantly using things four years later
to to manipulate the future as they are
trying to fix myself i try i tried it um
I take a lot of advice from people yeah
um I never go about it on my own that's
for sure yeah so Ted Cruz wouldn't like
you cuz he's a rebel he's a loner yeah
you like teammate I do I like to work
work together yeah love and peace guys
Ben what do you think I think that I'm
with you that I the mainstream media
makes an enormous mistake in and does a
disservice to covering important issues
when they recover everything in a horse
race doesn't matter what you say it only
matters what you say and how it relates
and I engage in it I love it I love the
race but i think really love it right
but not at the but it shouldn't come at
the expense of talking about like how
these people would govern and what that
would be
the difference here is that in order to
cover accurately what's happening in
Washington now you have to cover this
part of it because everything these guys
are doing has nothing to do with what
they accomplished now since all of them
actually acknowledge we can't be fundo
comp obamacare and eventually when i
start the government back up we have to
pay everybody back right well pretty
sure everyone saying that except for Ted
Cruz I feel like he still thinks he can
not funded and win this I don't think I
don't either way mate but will I said I
can't peer into the soul of a crazy
person yet right uh but what he mostly
wants was to be front and center right
and the voice of this sort of radical I
hate government I hate the people who
run government hate things the
government does yeah any worked you know
he's a 20-percent they're all like all
the guys you mentioned between ten and
twenty percent in the latest polls but
Ted Cruz is a guide elected to the
Senate like wednesday and now all of a
sudden in a straw poll he actually leads
among Republicans that's what he wanted
so you have to talk about it yeah it's
part of the problem here that also that
somehow this stuff is juicier because
these guys are all such characters I
feel like they're all cartoon characters
Rand Paul's hair the size of chris
Christie likely they're all sort of
cartoon characters and that's more
exciting than talking about like the
minutiae of a bill isn't it like you can
just make fun of them and that keeps it
in the discussion it makes it fun for
people that aren't really interested in
politics right but we can live tweet
speeches and events and it's fun for
everyone yeah is that part of elmo is
that I mean I do it all the time we yeah
yeah no that's fun I I do too yeah I
have no idea what I'm talking about I
just like to tweet so it's super fun but
it is a problem yeah is that part of the
problem that because the policy stuff is
just not the stuff that gets people
talking we could be sitting here
breaking down some policy and we get
sick speeds they they take advantage of
the fact that that the and the press to
their lot obviously you know your show
Dave and when when we do the young turks
and all these shows are dependent on
good reporters doing their jobs we have
information to talk about so they're
great reporters out there but as a whole
they don't take a lot of time explaining
stuff cuz they don't really know and
it's hard to get at I mean that of the
Affordable Care Act is confusing yeah
right and it's difficult and of course
reporting on what's wrong with the
Affordable Care Act now is pointless we
don't know what's wrong with it or
what's right with it it's a giant huge
bill and it needs a year yeah to breathe
and then obviously like Social Security
and you going fix the problems but that
requires I know there's a glitch so if
the shutdown the whole thing that
doesn't is nothing about what I just
said that works in a 24-hour news cycle
let alone forget 24 hours a four hour
news cycle yeah on cable in the internet
it just so this and these guys know that
so they make a big speech they make a
big Proclamation they make sort of
definitive points the press covers it
and they get their way yeah well you
know we talk about this all the time
here about how the mainstream media is
so untrustworthy i was watching fox news
the other day and they were like you
know look at the system the obama care
system the computers are crashing
because it's so inept and glitchy in
blah blah blah literally turn to MSNBC
they're showing the same screen of the
glitches and they're saying it's because
too many people were on there so it's
over you know because it's too good so
it's overloading the service and it's
like I'm pretty sure you're both lying I
don't know what's going on on CNN
they're just showing Anderson's hair for
like you know like who dis just nobody
actually is to like who knows what
what's right what's wrong yes I mean I
actually know again of course I come at
it with bias but I'm pretty sure it's a
lot closer to the msn be the thing
because when you offer people the chance
to get out there they're gonna think
yeah I'll do that especially every
single one of those people as a child
yeah and they'll think the first day
what i'ma do them a sign off I'm gonna
make sure that my family has health care
yeah so I would you know there you heard
it bend trust MSNBC slightly more than
he trusts fox news hey guys Rubin report
is brought to you by Cooper calm you can
get up to seventy-five percent off pet
toys choose all kinds of treats and more
the link is right down below click it
and use code RR for twenty percent off
your first purchase